why writers should educate themselves
all the way through their careers and
what are they using as those tools I
love that you asked that question so the
interesting thing is I have taught all
over the world and I have found that in
countries like Israel Australia Toronto
and London that the type of writers that
attend story events in ongoing education
are working writers versus in the US the
story events that are like you know the
bigger story events that are massive are
for usually I would say the highest
percentage of attendees are writers
across the US who had an idea and want
to make it happen versus working writers
and I definitely believe that that holds
writers back from creating longevity in
their careers I believe a writer should
always be educating should I always say
about myself that I'm a teacher for a
moment and a student for life and I am
constantly reading every book that comes
out on story and emotion and business
and anything that can make me move to a
higher level spiritually you know work
wise on a personal level like I am all
about the idea that we have to
constantly every day I wake up and think
about how do how can I be better than I
was yesterday and for the writer it
really is how can I expand my knowledge
of story through continuous learning as
well as my observance and absorption of
life
being able to communicate that in story
how can I continuously do that in a way
that will fuel my career
you think it's Western culture and the
emphasis on overconfidence a little bit
whereas many other cultures it's okay do
I do like there I sit there and I think
I look at these story events that have
all the top story people in the business
many of who you've interviewed and I
think why would you not take the
opportunity to continuously learn I've
been in the business 25 years like I
have seen every side of the business and
I always think you know why would you
not take a sounding board
many of these writers mean when you look
at Michael Haig and you look at Chris
Vogler and you have had these incredible
careers John Truby and you know Eric
Edson and there's so much that they have
to say that brings value to the story
process and that's important so ongoing
education in my view is the key to
creating a writing career that will last
so just to reiterate so in the States
you've seen many what may be what you
call baby writers I think you'd use that
term and it doesn't matter age it's just
in terms of experience right but then
outside of the states Europe and beyond
these are working right oh yes and
they're willing to yeah all that's the
question I always ask the question at
the beginning of an event how many of
you have sold a pilot or how many of you
are currently on staff and and
everywhere else it is mind-blowing to
see two-thirds of the room raised their
hand versus here you maybe see ten
people raise their hand you know and and
it's a very different thing and I I
think I don't know what that is like I
sit there now I can say my personal
then because I worked with so many
working writers I get writers of all
levels show up at those events but when
I do these big story events where
there's like twenty or thirty speakers
in my world I'm like are you kidding me
that's incredible like I want to get it
I want to I want to soak up another one
of my favorite story people as Dara
marks like I look at it and I think I
want to soak up like everything they've
learned and how they see story and how
it aligns with how I see story because
that makes me a better teacher you know
that makes me like in and I always loved
seeing like how we coin things in
different ways and it go it comes from
our worldviews and how we teach story
and I think what we're all trying to
master is teaching story in a way that
leads the writer to sell the story
that's what we all want in terms of
questions do you see a difference in the
type of question and even the tone that
you get in the us-based
groups versus I mean is there you know
there's always certain people in a class
that one I'll sort of debate the teacher
yeah there's those that have actually a
healthy curiosity and they know the
answer yeah yeah I would say well one
thing I found it's interesting between
the audiences like I definitely think
the u.s. audience absolutely have the
curiosity and I think that people want
to learn I definitely think that in the
u.s. we're connected with the idea of
the quickfix so I have an idea I want to
sell it and make it work and that's
definitely a part of it and whereas I
think like the writer in Australia is
not does not make the type of money that
the writer in the u.s. makes like many
Australian writers end up coming here
because they don't make the kind of
money but they they get the foundation
there and then they come here and
I think that you know I think that there
there is a tone in the questions
definitely from different countries
based on the world view of how the
writer is seen in that country I mean we
are very fortunate that the writer is
seen in a very strong light in the TV
world and the film world even though the
TV world the writer has more power so I
think it causes writers from around the
world to want to get their foundation in
their own culture and succeed there and
then come here so I definitely think
that I've noticed that a number of the
events that I've done internationally
that the writers who are I mean I I
remember in Australia that I met one
writer who had like four shows but was
still wanting to come to the u.s. and
wanting to expand because they looked at
the US as being the end-all be-all
as far because of the pay and because of
the way people see writers do you think
that film and television writing is open
to all sort of class and education level
where's with the literary world
especially in like let's say the East
Coast it's more of a closed network yeah
I definitely I mean I mean the literary
world its interest i I have worked with
several novelists but not near the
amount of novelists as I have with TV
and feature writers because that's my
background but I think I'm definitely
know that story this story and you're
going to benefit and learn from anyone
so I definitely think there are more
closed off communities and how they see
but I also think like there's a massive
trend right now toward the screenwriter
writing the book and then writing the
screenplay
so I think that's opening up interesting
the idea and I
I personally love that process because I
love the idea of really deeply going
into the internal story in the book and
then showing that in visual and action
in the adaptation into the screenplay so
then it creates this whole new viewer
which is the one that read them first
then they want to see weigh it against
the novel yeah and the writer has more
power to when they write the book and
then sell the film I'm thinking of like
Janet Fitch she did white Olien right
which is yeah a book I had been
recommended but I've never read it and
then I absolutely loved the movie and
now I'm almost afraid to read the book
yeah but it was just to me I've been
recommended and and that also happens of
are you an internal person the reason
I'm not a screen writer it's because I'm
I'm an internal writer and I know that
about myself hmm you know going back to
self-aware yes right yep
you